you believe in a lot of cases that men
and women have roles oh yeah if we're
walking up to the car and I don't open
your car door what do you say open the
door you better believe it no I
I daddy a sandwich
I will after I get out of the shower
we're going to take a look at uh some
videos these are all videos having to do
with gender roles and I assume I haven't
seen anything ahead of time but I assume
that these are all are mostly Tick Tock
videos so we're going to get insight
from tick tock on the question of gender
roles and I'm sure that the Insight will
be quite profound and indeed insightful
in reference to the passage that
discusses wife submitting to husbands I
asked what did women need protection
from the most common answer I got was
animals wild animals
and natural disasters
assuming this is the case is this
command still relevant in a modern
context or are men sincerely convinced
that they're out here saving us left and
right from bears and tsunamis Well yeah
if you ask a bunch of stupid people a
question you'll get stupid answers
Thomas's stupidest so there's there's uh
no surprise there but what do women need
protection from I mean first of all
that's actually not even necessarily a
very stupid answer first of all it may
be the case for you as someone living
you know in a in a comfortable
environment in the modern Western World
it may be the case for you that you
don't have to worry about animal attacks
that's the kind of like that's a real
threat for actually billions of people
who currently live on planet Earth right
now
that is the kind of thing and in fact
when we talk about you know like where
do we get the idea that men should be
protectors well this is an ancient idea
and it goes back to a time when things
like animal attacks were uh were
irrelevant threat to most people who
lived on earth the natural disasters if
you have a tornado bearing down on you
at this exact moment then it's it's
unlikely that a man will be able to step
in your way and like punch the tornado
and make it go away but I don't think
that's what people mean when they talk
about natural disasters here's one way
that we protect ourselves from natural
disasters I'll tell you one way is by
building uh homes that will be able to
withstand
natural disasters and who who are the
people building doing all the builds
like almost all the buildings I'm
reinforcing the head
that's great buddy
as soon as the zoning committee gives me
their approval I know the bank's gonna
release the money right now I'm just
asking anyone to just you know power
through okay if I was if I was to look
and I don't have the information right
in front of me and so anyone is free to
fact check me on this let's get to work
people but if I was to look at the
demographics for construction workers am
I going to find that it's 50 50 men and
women or am I going to find that nearly
every construction worker on the planet
is a man so that is actually an example
of men protecting women and themselves
and Society uh but there are many other
things as well that that um women would
need protection from you know crime
violence these are all very relevant
things like if you live in a city you
probably don't have to worry about a
lion chasing you down but you do have to
worry about criminals
um that's why if you live in a high
crime area or even if you don't live in
a high crime area and you're a woman
you're probably going to feel and much
safer if you have a man at home with you
there's there's a question for you you
take any woman at all I don't care how
feminist and how empowered they think
they are well they feel safer at night
knowing that a man is in their home like
if they're married
do they feel safer when they're when
their husband is there at night or if
they're home alone
I think for nearly every single woman
they'll say yeah I feel safer when a man
is there now flip it around
is there any man who feels safer at
night at home knowing that his wife is
there no I mean I can say say this as a
man I'm I I'm happy that my wife is
there I don't feel physically safer I
don't think to myself well if anybody
breaks in at least my at least my wife
is here to handle it so I think that
also tells you something about about the
the gender roles and how they still
apply are you one of the millions of
American men and women dealing with
premature hair thinning and hair loss or
maybe you're scared about inheriting
that thinning look because it runs in
the family well finally there's a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and unpleasant smells provia
Hair Care uses a safe natural ingredient
called procapital to effectively Target
the three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss probia supports
healthy scalp circulation and delivers
nourishing nutrients to strengthen hair
follicles and anchor them to your scalp
provia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower drain probably as
effective for men and women of any age
and safe uncolored treated and styled
hair provio Works guaranteed or 100 of
your money back it's that easy right now
new customers save over 50 percent off
on provia's introductory package at
proviahair.com Walsh YT see results for
yourself right now don't wait that's
proviahair.com
walshyt want you to be true to yourself
not restricted by what Society expects
of your agenda I mean it's me Dad Mom
and I believe you can do whatever you
want fight society's pressure put you in
a box girl boy man woman and here we are
one month into your life I'm outside
doing the matcha work while Mom's inside
cleaning and feeding you I understand
it's normal to have some things gendered
but we weren't like this before you and
honestly it worries me as your role
model but the lesson I'm learning here
is that there will be moments in life
where things we do our gen but it
doesn't mean that you're restricted by
your gender and your journey to
discovering your true self much love
yeah of course because if you want to
send a message to your how old's the
baby it's like a one month old baby yeah
if you want to send a message to your
baby the way to do it is to make a tick
tock video how about if you if you want
to impart lessons to your child and I
mean when they're infants it's a little
bit early they're not gonna understand
what you're saying but as they get a
little bit older uh how about you just
sit down and talk to them so that of
course tells us that you're not actually
talking to your kid you're talking to
society because you want to be applauded
for your uh enlightened attitude which
is not an enlightened attitude it's like
he's outside building something and it
feels the need to apologize for it to
the world like yeah I know I'm building
something and my wife is home uh caring
for the baby but don't make any
assumptions
even though we feel that we're
enlightened I would not send my wife out
to go build the shed while I'm at home
uh feeding the baby that's not going to
happen which only goes to show that even
the people who think that they are
Beyond gender roles and that they're
living a life beyond them even those
people really aren't because a lot of
what we call gender roles these are just
these are ingrained in you in in
humanity and they're not arbitrary is
the point if there's a reason why it
works out this way men are a certain way
women are a certain way women have
certain capabilities that men don't have
men have certain capabilities that women
don't have and the whole point of gender
roles okay it's not an arbitrary
designation that was invented by Society
to oppress you and to make you feel bad
it's more Society recognizing these
differences in men and women and these
capabilities that men have and these
capabilities of women have and and
saying to to the individuals well there
are responsibilities that come with that
you're a man that means you're going to
be uh stronger than your wife you know
you're going to have so so there's a
responsibility that comes with that
strength you're supposed to use that in
a certain way with great power comes
actually makes a lot of sense when you
think about it and you don't have to
think about it that hard to see that it
makes sense uh that'll do it we'll end
it there talk to you tomorrow godspeed
she'd never bothered
with people she'd hate
that's why the lady is a